la vue sous les décombres encore fumants
tu est impressionnante depuis le haut
des immeubles qui encercle le centre
commercial on se rend compte de
l'étendue des dégâts
ici les habitants étaient aux premières
loges pour voir l' incendie
c'est ma fille qui m'a dit maman le spar
est tentant de brûler je me suis levé et
j'ai vu l'ampleur des dégâts quoi j'ai
lu que ça commençait des flammes qui
sortaient ça m'a fait mal au coeur parce
que moi je faisais mes courses quand
même là ceux qui vivent là racontent ce
qu'ils ont vu ce qu'ils ont entendu
certains ont fait des vidéos sur leur
smartphone mais par peur de représailles
personne ne veut témoigner à visage
découvert je vous écris donc ici de
pousser leurs idéaux plusieurs fois deux
manches à rien par avance et après le
recul et une fois après l'entraînement
dans le magasin une après je l' ai vu
monsieur sortir du htc l'épreuve les
grenats khroub elles ont été un enfer de
l'ordre nous avons voulu nous croit
impossible d'apercevoir quoi que ce soit
à l'intérieur des bâtiments en partie
effondré tout peut s'écrouler à tout
moment la police et les pompiers garde
le périmètre de sécurité
nous avons retrouvé l'un des commerçants
victimes de l'incendié
j'essaie de rentrer à quelqu'un qu'il
m'a dit qu'il ya là exploser tout ça il
faut pas reprocher tout ça depuis vos
l'inquiéter on n'a pas approché après
vous aviez beaucoup de choses dans votre
magasin beaucoup de marchandises elle
était plein il était rempli au fond dans
le quartier c'est la consternation
on est venu depuis ici depuis bébé je
n'ai que mes parents je n'ai avec mes
frères mes nièces
voilà quoi c'est malheureux de voir un
magasin comme ça crame et qu'on a connu
plus de bas vicois des médias les là
parce que j'avais mise en culture
j'allais gérer la viande à l'aise dans
les grands magasins
la police scientifique a commencé son
travail d' enquête
de nombreuses questions restent encore
ce soir en suspens